In the previous project, you learned
how to construct models of data, and
then use those models to generate
predictions about the future.
In this unit, we're going to cover
one of the methods for doing that,
called supervised learning.
Supervised learning is a type of machine
learning where we feed our system what
we call labeled examples.
Labeled examples means we give the
system some information that it uses to
understand the data
that we're giving it.
So for example if we were building our
system to recognize my face, we would
give it some pictures of my face and
some pictures of other people's faces.
And we would actually tell the system
these pictures are of David and
these pictures are of somebody else.
And it would use that information to
develop its understanding over time.
In other domains,
we would see things like in health care,
we would give it some
examples of patients.
And we would tell it whether or
not those patients ended
up with a certain disease.
Or in education, we would give
it examples of students and
tell it whether or not each of those
students actually ended up graduating.
So the system is using some information
that we give it about the success or
failure of those different examples to
construct its understanding about what
leads to that success or failure.